what's up Mary how we doing
I'm good how are you we are rocking and
rolling so how's how's everything y'all
doing okay
we're doing okay we're having a few
issues that's why I'm calling you all
right so what's up how can I help
well I am part of a blended family and
my son recently moved back home and
we're having some issues how old is he
he is 19 about to be 20. okay
and what do you move home from
um well he was just gone for a few
months he got a job he finally got a
pretty decent job and he went to go move
in with his girlfriend
and then he he called me one day and
asked if he could come back home so that
um that wasn't really working out and
one of his co-workers had just rented a
house and he wanted to move in with him
it was closer to work and it sounded
good so I was like okay but I talked it
over with my husband and we agreed that
it would be for six weeks and he would
have to there'd be no drugs or alcohol
allowed no girls allowed no he had to
clean up after himself and then pay a
hundred dollars a week in rent you
basically gave him the rules that I have
for my 11 year old
yeah is that is that a state of his I
mean is that a signal of his emotional
state as a 20 year old
pretty much because
um up until he moved out just a couple
months ago he literally was doing
nothing okay so so what's going on
um so at first he was doing really good
for like the first four weeks he was
paying his rent cleaning up after
himself
clean him up after himself he was going
to work he seemed you know to have a
good self-esteem and then all of a
sudden
um he started not going to work as often
as he was and stopped cleaning up after
himself stopped paying rent and then he
called me out to talk to him one day and
I walked out to his car with him and he
said he started crying and said that
um I didn't know him nobody knew the
real him that he wasn't a good person
and that nobody understood him and I I
just I didn't know what was going on so
I told him I was like regardless of
what's Happening you know or what you've
done I still love you nothing's going to
make me not love you I said just talk to
me and
um
he said that he's not emotionally
connected with anyone since
um his brother died and he died four
years ago in an accident he was 18. okay
and and we've been getting through that
pretty well I thought and then you know
I was just kind of waiting for the bomb
to drop and he said that the only one
that he's emotionally connected to since
then was my husband's youngest daughter
who is 17 and she doesn't live with us
um but he proceeded to tell me that
they've
um been in a romantic relationship
and you know I I was stunned and told
them you know all the things that could
go wrong with that that it was an
appropriate and
I didn't really know what to say but
um it didn't end very well
um I tried to tell my husband which
obviously he didn't take it very well
and now over the past week he's not
they're not talking to each other now
she's mad at him because he told us
and he's just kind of regressed back to
himself he's not talking to anybody he's
openly smoking weed in the driveway like
he's just shut down and I you know I
don't I don't know what to do I want to
help him but at the same time
I don't want it to destroy you know the
entire family
so I'm just I don't know what to do to
help him
and not destroy us
so you you cannot he's a 20 year old man
okay yes he's got some trauma right he's
got some hard stuff
he's a 20 year old man though
right and he suffered a horrific loss of
his brother that was hard for the family
and he still should not have to have an
Elise that he's got to clean up after
himself as a 20 year old right yeah yes
and so any damage that happens to the
family because you decide to draw
boundaries
are not going to be quote unquote your
fault okay okay
and you're going to have to
um unhook yourself from the other
people's choices when they run up
against your boundaries the things that
you're going to do to keep your family
safe okay
okay also
um you're gonna love the you're going to
hold up your end of the bargain you told
him no matter what you tell me I'm gonna
love you and you're going to keep doing
that right
right and that means you're going to
love him and you're going to be there
for him and you're not going to enable
them
right
and he's going to have to face the music
that if he was in a sexual relationship
with a 17 year old as a 20 year old
depending on what state he's in he just
committed a felony
and that felony was committed against a
child
and that child happens to be your the
daughter of your husband
yes right and so there's going to be
some face of the music on this deal
again you will not be the person who
destroyed your family
right right the more you hang on to that
the more you are going to enable him
to continue to hurt a child to continue
to knock at the help that he desperately
desperately needs because you're trying
to own and control the outcomes of this
deal and you can't he's got to take
responsibility as a hurting 20 year old
man
right that he can't sleep with 17 year
olds
he can't smoke weed in his mom's house
he can't fill in the blank fill in the
blank fill the blank right
right so what he's got to have right now
is the the your love and your compassion
and your accountability all wrapped up
into one
one one package real real quick because
he's really close to doing something he
can't come back from
right whether that's hurting himself
whether that is
he's going to get himself in trouble
he's going to cross the line he can't
come back from
well his day to move out of our house
was supposed to be next week and I still
want to hold to that okay
um I'm nervous about it but at the same
time I feel like if I've extended any
further like you said I'm enabling him
yeah and but I also want you to be
willing to extend an olive branch and
take them out and say what is your plan
I will help you make a plan yeah it's
not going to be here but I'm not
abandoning you I want to help you
um why aren't you and I don't know if
you and your husband can talk about like
we might help you with counseling
resources we might help you with
recovery resources and things like that
but it's not going to be living here
because you got a job and he's clearly
got skills and he's also clearly got
hurt right so it's all wrapped up there
together he's gonna have to face some
music with your husband now
yes well we had initially we had planned
on taking 100 a week rent saving that
for him and then adding 400 for his
birthday to give him his his thousand
dollar emergency starting fund of course
with him coming home
you know with bags of weed I don't feel
like that's going to help him at this
point well here's the Magic The Magic of
the of an emergency fund is part the
money
but that's not really it the emergency
fund is a psychological thing
that I went bananas I sold stuff I just
ran as fast as I could and I was able to
do this and so just handed somebody a
thousand bucks is not the same as them
grinding and grinding there's a it's a
it's a psychological thing right uh it
would have been a great gift it would
have been cool but it would not have
been effective as him going out and
grinding it out
right and earning a thousand bucks and
showing and proving to himself baby
steps I could do this right yeah right
but all that to say is this you and your
husband have to get on the same page
today
and if not today you let him know like
hey we've got to have this conversation
tomorrow
right okay and you need your husband to
um be as level-headed as poss as a dad
of a
daughter who's been
um raped and or sexually assaulted by an
adult male can be right which is not
always very much so and you're gonna
have to figure out what's next steps
okay and then at some point he's going
to have to address
your husband his his stepdad at some
point you'll have to reconcile that
relationship there and then he's going
to have to move out of your house
yes and he's gonna have to remove out of
your house with the best you can letting
him know that he love him I would
recommend I'd say this all the time and
I would tell you the same thing too
um I would write him a letter that he
can hold in his hand and go back to and
go back to and go back to and I'd
probably if I was his mom make that a
practice maybe once a week it will help
you clarify your thoughts and get all
that spinning spirally stuff out onto a
piece of paper
and also it's going to give him
something to hold because someone who's
an addict someone who's suffering with
trauma they are so so good with walls
right and defense mechanisms they throw
him up so fast
right as soon as you say you've got to
move out but I love you they're already
out they're not listen to words you're
saying they are into defense mode and
you hate me and you're going to ruin my
life and why don't you fill in the blank
right if they're holding that letter
they can Circle back to it and circle
back to it and circle back to it and
they can read it again or read it again
and read it again
okay
um and even if he takes that letter and
you find it in the trash on your his way
out it's still a benefit to you for
having gotten your heart and thoughts
out on a piece of paper
okay but the greatest thing you can give
him right now is a plan
like a detailed plan here's where you
can go here's how we're going to support
you or not support you here's what we
expect of you if you want to move back
all those kind of stuff and two is your
accountability your boundaries
okay and and I'm I don't want to
sugarcoat this it may get real bad Mary
yes okay
yes
are you ready for that
I think I am I have gotten there I've
been uh dealing with his boundaries for
a year and a half two years now and
I've listened a lot but I've it's
finally to that point where I think I'm
going to be able to do what I need to do
okay
um and let him know he's always got your
heart and you'll always be there to meet
him for coffee and to talk him through
what's next but that doesn't always mean
he's got access to smoke weed in your
house that doesn't always mean he's got
access to your money into your the
children in your home et cetera et
cetera right right right
okay well thank you so much I appreciate
you taking the time no I appreciate you
making the call and I think the the
broader lesson for all of us is is a lot
of these relationships especially when
they're
young adults man drawn boundaries
sometimes for the first time especially
when you're dealing with trauma
it's not just a magic solution it gets
real real hard
oh and Mary if you get a hint a hint
that he's going to hurt himself
you call in the calvary you call every
emergency number that you know if you
get a hint that he's in some sort of
inappropriate relationship with a minor
you call in everybody you call the
police you call everybody into that
situation right that's your job
um
because there sounds like there was a
romantic relationship with a miter you
have to report that too even though it's
your child
um you're gonna have to report that
I don't if some laws 17 is is
um
of legal consent age and so depending on
the state you're in y'all can worry if
y'all can figure that out with your
local authorities but
um he's going to have a Reckoning with
that situation
um
man that can get real messy too that can
get real messy with your marriage and
you and your husband have to be super
intentional about being united in this
deal
um
man there's not always happy endings
here I really really will be thinking
about you guys as y'all move forward and
um you and your husband here want to get
a counselor to help you all unpack this
and work through this because it's going
to be hard hard hard hard